we have been on vacation I know I've
been checking my email during the break
and been getting the emails from people
saying what's going on has the show been
canceled uh did you fire yourself no
none of those things have happened we've
just been on vacation that's it but we
are back tomorrow with number one a
brand-new show we will preview the
presidential debate we will also be
speaking early this week to attorney
Mike Papantonio whose new book law and
disorder features among many interesting
characters a blogger named david pakman
i will talk to Mike Papantonio about how
he uh sort of wrote in the inspiration
for the character that we know is david
pakman in law and disorder and of course
we're going to be covering the
presidential debate now what i do want
to mention to you is we've had this
membership special running during the
vacation where if you go to david
pakman.com slash membership and use
coupon code huge 50 hu GE 50 all one
word you can get a fifty percent
discount on membership for life and that
includes the commercial free audio and
video streams of the show this includes
the bonus show available only to our
subscribers includes the archive of
shows dating all the way back to when
the program started all that stuff is a
bit available to members the coupon code
huge 50 ends when the vacation and so
last chance to take advantage of that
david pakman.com slash membership you
select any membership that you want use
the coupon code huge 50 and you can keep
that half price membership for
absolutely as long as you want